[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a film based on the real-life
story of the youngest warrior of world
war ii called soldier boy
spoilers ahead watch out and take
[Music]
care the movie begins in russia where a
family of three sit by the river
enjoying their time the youngest of them
sergey eliashkov boasts to his elder
brother and mother about him being on
top of a tree when suddenly german
fighter jets fly overhead the mother
asks her kids to quickly hide in the
bushes but the six-year-old claims he is
not scared and strikes the jet with a
slingshot to everyone's surprise he
manages to hit the jets and explode them
but when he looks around his family is
gone sergey wakes up frightened from the
dream and calls for his mother just then
someone knocks on his door
assuming it is his mother he runs
towards it but a neighbor woman comes in
panicking she thanks god for keeping him
alive and informs him that his mother
and brother are dead
the little boy cannot comprehend what
she is saying and wants to stay in the
house to wait for his mother the woman
tells him that the germans have attacked
them and that he should run away
just then some soldiers approach their
house the woman makes sergey run out
through the window but is shot dead
before she can join him the little
six-year-old is now on his own with no
family and friends as sergey runs away
from the house he sees his whole
neighborhood burning behind him he calls
for his mother in vain and runs away
from there
after running for a while he ends up in
the middle of the woods the little kid
starts to call for his mother to come
and get him because he is lost
that night he stays in the jungle
the following morning we see him drink
water from a river when the enemy
soldiers approach his way
sergey knowing that they are dangerous
quickly hides inside a tree's roots he
is startled when a snake comes nearby
but doesn't utter a word or run away
sergei is more scared of the soldiers
than of the snake
the soldiers eat by the river and go
away after which sergey takes their
leftover food and devours it for the
night
however by the end of the day the little
boy is exhausted he hasn't had a proper
meal in two days and has been walking
with no destination
he falls down as he limps but doesn't
stop walking while on his way he sees
wild berries and devours them but just
then an explosion occurs behind him
taking him by surprise
the boy gets dizzy and starts to
hallucinate someone coming behind him
however even in such conditions he
stands brave and tells the person he has
a rifle and is not scared he limps
forward but falls unconscious after a
while
while he is asleep two soldiers approach
him the scene cuts to the russian army
base where commander kuznetsov waits for
his patrol soldiers they come in with a
little kid who is injured and weak
when the soldiers claim they are on his
side the little boy opens up and
introduces himself
the soldiers laugh when the kid shakes
his hand with the commander suggesting
he introduce himself too
the soldiers feel affectionate with a
little kid and circle him around
they make him drink water and feed him
even the otherwise cold commander takes
care of the kid a nurse named catch
addresses sergey's wounds and is charmed
by his personality too the kid asks her
to draw a tank on his wounds because he
wants to be a soldier when he grows up
even the injured soldiers talk to the
kid and feel lighter
sergey is fascinated with the
commander's gun in his batch the
commander 2 answers all the little boy's
questions and lets him play with his
honorary pistol after taking the bullets
out
sergey shows him the tank drawn on his
stomach and boasts about being a soldier
himself
the boy is healing very quickly the
nurse katya asks the commander to let
the boy stay with the battalion but he
disagrees claiming that it won't be safe
he wants to send sergey to an orphanage
the soldiers spend all their free time
with sergey
he is visited by many throughout the day
they bring him food sent by their
families from afar and even let him play
with their binoculars
one day a soldier goes to the commander
to ask him to let the boy stay with the
battalion the soldiers have grown a
close connection with the kid and think
of him as their own
his presence takes the weight of war off
their chest
however the commander is adamant about
sending the boy to the orphanage for his
own safety the following day the enemies
attack and many soldiers are hurt a
vehicle comes to fetch sergey to take
him to the orphanage the commander
breaks the news to the kid and gives him
a wooden honorary pistol as a gift the
boy in turn hugs him claiming that he is
scared for the commander's safety the
commander melts in his embrace and
changes his mind he asks sergey to stay
with the soldiers as his son
that night the soldiers look for little
soldier clothes for the little boy they
are over the moon to have sergey stay
with them
the commander wakes sergei up and gives
him the clothes he wears them and runs
around looking like a real soldier
the others start calling him their
little soldier boy
as the kid runs around the germans
launch an air attack on the battalion
the soldiers quickly take sergey to a
safe place and fight the others
the number of injured soldiers grows
rapidly sergey wants to make himself
useful so he brings water to thirsty
soldiers one of them asks him to read a
letter sent by his family because he has
a bandage over his eyes the little boy
wants to help but doesn't know how to
read he takes the letter and starts
making up the things written on it
claiming that the soldier's cow is safe
back home
when the soldier says he doesn't have a
cow the others tell him to go along with
the story and laugh
he reads everyone else's letters in the
same fashion and cheers them up
in the following scene we see katya and
the commander talking the two seem to be
attracted to each other but do not
confess their feelings
later sergey tells the commander that he
is of the orderly position in the
battalion and starts introducing himself
as one
however the boy then sees one of the
soldiers stationed destroyed from the
attack the commander teaches him to take
his hat off to pay respect to the dead
soldier
the next day he insists the commander
give him a mission and is given a task
to distribute the letters among the
soldiers he completes his task
efficiently and even makes the soldiers
dance for him the following day sergey
goes a little far from the base with his
binoculars as he is playing with it he
sees someone's leg moving from inside a
haystack he rushes back to the battalion
and tells the soldiers about his
findings
the soldiers are skeptical but go with a
boy anyway
when they reach near the haystack they
are alerted to see two german spies
hiding underneath
the spies are arrested and the kid is
praised for his intelligence that night
the commander shows sergey the legal
papers for his adoption
he is now officially the kid's father
sergey knows of the commander's feelings
for katya so to repay his kindness he
takes him to confess to her but the two
see her talking to a different man and
wrongfully assume she is interested in
someone else
the base is attacked by the germans
again
this time sergei helps the soldiers with
all his might by supplying ammunition to
the soldiers in the front line but the
soldiers there command him to go back to
the shed because it is too dangerous
outside
when he comes to the shed he sees the
commander and others panicking because
the phone's connection with the colonel
is lost
a soldier is sent to fix the broken
wires
sergey follows the soldier and cece has
been fatally wounded he asks the dying
soldier how he can fix the wires and
does it himself
the connection comes back and more
troops are called the six years old
saves everyone's life
later we see the commander and catch it
talking by the river the commander
finally confesses his love for her and
asks her to be sergey's mother
kanye is over the moon but before she
can say anything a soldier approaches
them and gives the commander a letter
saying they have been dispatched from
the base
the following day all the soldiers leave
for their new base along with sergey
however on their way they come across a
minefield that blows off some of their
vehicles the commander is hurt while the
group's orderly who sergey was close
with dies in the explosion
he cries and hugs the commander they
carry the injured ones with them and
continue their journey to their new base
when they finally reach the other base
they meet the commander's leader the
general he too is impressed by the kids
ambition and congratulates the commander
for having such a smart kid
the following day their division is
awarded a guards banner and so is the
boy he promises to save his country when
the general gives him his badge
one night their base is attacked
brutally and the commander is trapped
under the ruins sergei cries for his
father and tries to save him
he calls the other soldiers who finally
bring the commander out
the next day sergey approaches an
injured commander his hands were hurt
while trying to save the commander the
kid is now an inseparable part of the
team
he doesn't have a family beside them and
moves wherever they go in the war the
movie ends as the regiment is seen
moving to another base
a voice in the background narrates that
he even took part in the stalingrad
battle and reached poland with the
soldiers he is currently known as the
world's youngest soldier ever and the
legendary story of his bravery is now
spread for the whole world to hear
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching